hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a next desk so i realized i've owned
one for a while and there's been one in
the background in my videos plenty of
times and i got a lot of questions about
it after i posted my updated gear list
on kit and there aren't that many videos
about it so i want to make this quick
one basically if you have cable
management goals or if you just want a
high-tech desk this is something to at
least consider on the surface next desk
is a pretty normal desk plus some
high-tech design some sick features and
some hydraulic legs that let it move at
its core it's what's called a sit stand
desk you've probably heard of it you can
sit at it or you can stand at it it's
supposed to be healthier blah blah
whatever i just feel better standing up
once in a while and there are plenty of
other motorized sit stand desks but this
one just happens to be what i would say
is top-notch like the highest end one
you can get or at least that i've found
there's this controller up at the front
and it has some up and down buttons of
course and you can set up to three
presets for heights i generally have two
my standing height and my sitting height
but it definitely goes even higher and
even lower than i need up to 51 inches
high or 24 and a half inches low
my standing height is usually around 46
47 inches because that's the height
where your arms are parallel to the desk
while using the keyboard and the mouse
that's i guess the ergonomically correct
way to line it up and sitting you just
roll a chair up and you're good to go
now i said it is high end it does have a
couple of features or a couple options
that make it a little better than just a
plain table right so number one cable
management you can get it with this
cover on the back that you can slot
cables into that works in hand with
number two a built-in power strip on the
underside of the desk this is really
clutch so everything on the desk can
curl around and plug into this power
strip on the bottom and then that power
strip is just one cable that plugs into
the wall so it was actually supposed to
be bolted to the bottom of the desk here
but i guess mine got dislodged during
shipping so i just stuffed it in the
vanity cover but same effect you now
only have one cable coming off the back
of the desk also bolted to the bottom of
the desk is the controller that's used
to sync the legs up and power everything
so this is what helps the hydraulic legs
move and raise up smoothly so this desk
can lift a lot of weight and it can also
double as a video tool to get some
motion into shots if you want to instead
of getting fancy with a tripod so it's
smooth to raise up and then stop and
it's also smooth to lower itself it's
not something you think about until you
have it but it's pretty neat and nice to
have also this grass is not real okay
moving on there are several versions of
this desk this wood one is nextdesk
terra
and the one at my apartment you've seen
is metal it's the nextdesk air pro and
the difference between the pro and
non-pro models is the number of legs
basically the non-pro has two legs and
the pro has four legs which actually
helps a lot with support i think the
biggest downside of this terra is
there's a slight bowing right in the
middle if you have something really
heavy there or if you press down on it
or lean on it a lot just a slight
flexing but you probably won't have this
problem if you don't go with the
extended version of this desk this is
the extended version
and it only has two legs so it's like
the worst case scenario for flex and
yeah the metal ones do not flex at all
so just something to note anyway that's
pretty much it just wanted to give you
guys a sneak peek of some of the tech
that's going into the new studio
anything that's tech related as i set it
up i'll probably make a video about it i
already ordered a custom nextdesk as
well i'll get that in a couple weeks
you'll probably see the details of that
on twitter and snapchat etc but that's
it for this one that's your next desk
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace